I've been trading for 14 years. Earlier
this year, I broke the world record for
the largest prop firm payout of two and
a half million dollars. And if I were to
start over from day one, I would have
focused on mastering one concept, the
swing failure pattern. Today, I'm going
to break down the basics, common
mistakes, and teach you the most
powerful tool I still use to this day.
Now, let's get into what a real swing
failure looks like. All right, so the
first thing we actually need to know is
we need to understand what swing points
are. Now, what are swing points? Simply
put, a swing low is a candle where both
the candle before it and after it have
higher lows. And a swing high is a
candle where both the candle before it
and after it have lower highs. So, in
this example, we have three candle a
three candle pattern. We have a down
close candle, which creates a low, and
then we have a lower low, and then a
higher low. So, this second candle here
becomes a bullish swing point. And vice
versa, for a bearish swing point, we
have a high, a higher high, and then a
lower high. So, on a lower time frame,
this is actually a low time frame
reversal. Now, it's important to
understand what swing points are because
in a bullish market environment, you
will consi- -stently see swing lows
being put into place, and that usually
gives you an idea where the market is
going to continue in that specific
direction. And on the other hand, if
we're in a bearish market environment,
we are going to consistently see swing
highs being put in place, and the market
continuing lower. So, overall, if we
look at a higher time frame and we see
swing lows being put into place and the
market is overall bullish, you can
anticipate that the trend is going to
continue higher. So, what I typically do
that helps me determine buys for the
next day, I'll sit down at night and
plot out all of the swing points. Now,
when these swing points are being
created, just understand that there are
traders that are entering the market
that are going to put their stop losses
below bullish swing points and above
bearish swing points. Now, when they do
this, this creates liquidity in the
market. And the two major drivers of a
market are liquidity and order flow. So,
as new swing points are being created in
the market, just understand that there
are more and more participants that are
possibly entering that market and
generating liquidity because they are
placing orders in the market. So, even
if they market enter into a trade, they
are setting additional orders at their
stop loss and take profit. Now, again,
this is a very important foundational
piece in your trading to understand
which direction the market wants to go
overall. And I just want to point out
that swing points aren't yet confirmed
until the third candle closes. So, if
you see a low being put into place and
you see a a higher low on the next
candle, but that candle is still
trading, it is not a confirmed swing
point until that candle closes. So, for
example, let's say each one of these
candles is an hourly candle and we have
the closures of the first two candles.
So, let's just say that this third
candle is still printing, right? There's
still time left for the candle closure.
You know, that might be anywhere from 59
minutes all the way down to 1 minute
left. Now, a swing point is not
confirmed until this third candle
closes. And I've seen many, many times
where the last 5 or 10 minutes this
candle might reverse and then print a
lower low, in which case we will not
have a confirmed bullish swing point.
So, just make sure when you're trying to
identify swing points in the live market
that you're waiting for that third
candle to close before you actually
identify that this is a bullish or
bearish swing point. All right, so now
you can mark your swing highs and lows.
That's your foundation. But here's the
thing, swing points alone, they won't
tell you where to enter a trade. Now,
what you need to know next is how to
spot when a swing point is setting up to
fail. Now, there's a repeating pattern
that happens before these failures. And
once you see it, you'll never look at
these swing points the same way again.
But before I get into that, I've used
this next concept to break the world
record at Apex. Now, if you use the code
Jada at checkout, you'll get 80% off all
evals. I'll also leave a link down in
the description. So, what is this next
concept? It's called the swing failure
pattern. And a swing failure pattern
happens when price breaks a previous
swing high or low, it triggers the stops
or breakout traders, and then quickly
reverses back inside the range. So, it
indicates that the breakout is failing
and that failure is the signal. So, as
you can see here, we have our old
bullish swing point and you guys can see
here that this next candle took out this
previous swing point. So, just imagine
that anybody that got long on one of
these candles, they put their stop loss
down here. Now, this candle here is
coming in and triggering all the stop
losses of these traders that went long.
And same thing here, if traders got
short, they're going to put their stop
losses above this swing high. And this
candle right here is going to come and
trigger all of those stop losses. Now,
what is the failure? Typically, when we
get a closure back inside of the range.
So, just like I mentioned, this next
candle, you know, if there's still time
left, you need to let this candle finish
out and close to see if it's actually
going to reject the low and close back
inside of the range. So, if there's any
time left in this candle, you have to
let it close to confirm the pattern.
Now, what we're going to do after we get
this closure and confirmation is we're
going to anticipate the next couple
hourly candles to print in the opposite
direction. And this is where you're
allowed to drop down into the lower time
frames to find your specific entry
model. Now, why are swing failure
patterns so important and why are they
such a prevalent part of my trading? So,
what do they actually indicate? Okay, an
a swing failure pattern or SFP shows you
where traders got baited and then
punished, which usually means smart
money's taking the other side of the
trade. And that's exactly what we're
trying to do. Okay, as a trader, you're
trying to trade like the counterparty to
most retail traders because as we all
know, you know, 85% of retail traders
are losing money in the markets. So,
what you're trying to do is actually
enter where they're getting stopped out.
Now, what I used to do and the way that
liquidity raids or turtle soups are
taught is that you're supposed to just
go long as soon as we take out a
previous swing low. Now, the problem
that this causes is as it's breaching
the low, it's very hard to identify
where do I put my stop loss or where do
I enter? Because what happened to me for
many, many years, and I lost thousands
of dollars doing this, what I be I would
enter as soon as we would lose the low,
and I wouldn't know where to put my stop
loss. And unfortunately, that market
just kept trading lower and lower. And
then eventually, it might have turned
around, reclaimed the low, and by then,
I'm already stopped out for the day.
I've already hit my max loss. So,
instead of just trading liquidity raids
or turtle soups, I added this filter as
a confirmation. I waited for the next
candle to get a closure back above the
range before I started hunting on the
lower time frames. So, just as a quick
exercise, I'm going to run you guys
through price action on Nasdaq from the
beginning of December to show you how
many times these swing failure patterns
appear and how many trades actually come
from them. So, as you guys see here,
I've marked out this swing high and this
swing low. On the following day, we run
out that swing low, and let's say you
can even mark out this swing low here.
Once we get the closure back into the
range, we're looking for a a
continuation move just on the next
couple candles. We don't need to
anticipate that it's going to run all
the way to this liquidity because we're
going to trade on the lower time frame,
and we're really only trying to take
advantage of maybe two or three hours
out of this trading session. And then,
we're done for the day. So, what do we
have? We have this swing failure
pattern. So, we get a raid on the low.
Right, again, we're not trying to just
trade as soon as we take out the low.
Okay? Cuz again, let's say if you just
wanted to go long as soon as we take out
this swing low. So, just as an example,
and exactly what I talked about before,
is we don't want to just go long as soon
as you take out a swing low. Because as
you can see, we take out this swing low,
but if you were to enter long as soon as
it takes out that swing low, you might
have gotten stopped out because maybe
you put your stop loss below this swing
low, right? And it just keeps running
down to that level. What we're waiting
for is a rejection of these swing lows,
and we don't get that until this candle
closes. Okay? So, this specific hourly
candle could have been trading up and
down this entire hour. But as soon as it
closes, that gives us the confirmation
that this is a swing failure pattern.
And what we're going to do on the next
candle is we're going to anticipate a
long entry on a lower time frame using
whatever entry model you want to use to
position ourselves for maybe the next
two, three, or even four hours. Okay?
So, we even have a shorter-term swing
failure pattern. Okay? So, maybe we have
a PM session trade. Okay? So, we have
this candle that that a swing failure
pattern. And then, we're going to start
hunting on the next couple candles,
okay? Maybe this candle stops you out,
but the next couple hours, right? 2 3 4
5 hours, we get that retracement back
into the range. The following day, we
have this old swing high. Guys can see
here that we've rated it and then gotten
a nice bearish closure. Okay, so when
I'm looking for swing failures, I
actually like seeing bearish candles
after taking out swing points, right?
And vice versa, I like seeing bullish
candles after taking out swing points.
So just because we get a swing failure
pattern, doesn't necessarily mean that
we're trying to go long straight away.
All right, a bullish candle after taking
out lows is much better than a bearish
candle after taking out lows. So here
again, we get a nice swing failure
pattern, and then the next couple hours,
right? Get 1 2 hours that are bearish.
And honestly, on an intraday basis, this
is all you need. Now, this setup occurs
during London. Now, let's say we're
looking for a setup during New York. And
just like I mentioned, a bullish candle
that creates a SFP is much more
important than a bearish one. So even
though this is an SFP, as I mentioned,
you took it we took out the low, but
this candle closed bearish. So maybe you
don't want to look for a trade on this
specific setup. So if we drop down to a
lower time frame, maybe we're going to
draw out a fib and wait for a
retracement back into equilibrium. So
once we get this bullish swing failure
pattern, what we're going to do is try
and anticipate the next couple candles
to close bullish. And maybe what we're
going to do is drop down to a lower time
frame and wait for price to enter a
discount before we try and start hunting
longs. And as you can see, this market
eventually traded up towards where? This
previous swing point all the way back
here. And then what do we get? We get
another swing failure pattern here, and
then the market trades lower. All right,
going forward to the next day, we have a
swing point here. During New York
session, we get a nice closure here and
we're anticipating the next two to three
four five candles maybe to trade higher.
And you'll usually notice the candle
that created the swing failure is a good
place to have a higher time frame stop
loss. So here, this is a bullish swing
failure pattern because this is the
candle that closed back into the range.
This low should be protected. All right,
going forward into the rollover, we can
see that we have this swing point and
then we had a closure back inside of it,
and then we're anticipating the next
couple candles to trade lower.
Eventually, it does, but obviously, on
the lower time frame, maybe we're not
trading Asia. But, you guys can see that
this pattern does eventually play out.
All right, going forward to the next
day, we have these swing points. You
guys can see here that we've rated this
swing point. Again, we're not trying to
short as soon as it takes out that high,
we're waiting for the closure of this
next candle. So, once we get the closure
of this specific candle, we have a swing
failure because that closes back inside
of the range, and then we start hunting
an entry on the lower time frame. All
right, again, going forward, what we're
going to do is try and find a swing
failure pattern on the next day. You
guys can see here that we've taken out
this swing low. We got a nice closure,
and then trying to find a lower time
frame entry the next couple hours. Okay,
so we have one, two hours. Okay, inside
of these two hours, there is a trade
inside of this hourly candle on the
lower time frame. So, as this candle's
trading lower, this low should be
protected. The following day, we have
this swing high, and as I mentioned,
something to avoid is we're not going
short as soon as you take out the high.
We're waiting for confirmation that
they're going to reject the high. And we
don't get that until this candle here.
But, once we have the closure that we
rejected this high, then we can start
hunting a short on the next couple
candles. All right, coming into the next
day, let's say we don't have any swing
lows in here that were really were being
rated. So, none of these candles in here
are swing lows other than this one, but
we didn't get a raid on this candle
here. Okay, the next swing low is this
one back here from the prior day. Once
we get a closure back above here, we're
anticipating the next couple candles to
try and position long to maybe trade
higher into some level of liquidity up
here. Okay, on this specific day, if
you're looking for a swing failure
pattern, we actually don't get one,
which is totally fine. There are no
swing points in here that are being
rated. So, if we don't get a raid, then
maybe we're not going to take a trade
because what we're looking for are
retail traders being stopped out or
smaller players being stopped out and a
confirmation that larger players are
trying to send the market the other
direction. All right, going forward
here, we do have a swing failure pattern
here. As you guys can see, this market
kind of just chopped around. So, you can
see that these patterns don't always
work. We don't have a 100% hit rate on
these patterns, but they are very, very
high. I would say they're over 60%. Then
on Tuesday, we're going to plot out
obvious swing points, and we're going to
wait for a swing failure pattern. So,
here we get a nice closure above here on
this hourly candle, right? We're not
going to try and hunt longs until this
next hourly candle. And as you can see
here, the next couple candles do trade
higher. This day was a bit choppy, but
let's say we plot out our swing highs.
Now, this is a swing failure here
because we took out the high and then
closed back in the range. Now, this
would have been a very, very short-term
trade, okay? This would have only lasted
an hour because if we take out this
swing low, we get another swing failure
pattern going the opposite direction.
All right, so we have this swing low, we
have a nice swing failure pattern, and
then the next two candles print higher.
The following day, we have a swing high.
Once we get a swing failure pattern,
obviously as I mentioned, it's better to
see a bearish candle after taking a
swing high. So, maybe we're not going to
try and hunt a position until this
candle. All right, once we get a bearish
candle that confirms a swing failure
pattern, we can anticipate the next
couple candles or series of candles
trading lower. Again, here we have a
bearish swing failure pattern. So, if
you were to try to position yourself
inside of this hourly candle, there is
an intraday trade in here as this market
is trading higher. So, we get a bearish
swing failure, right? We take out this
swing point, we reject it. This candle
right here, there is a trade in here
that is going to last maybe two to three
hours taking out this swing low down in
here. And then what do we get? We get a
bullish swing failure. So, obviously
this market is in a range. Now, this
concept works in ranging and in trending
markets, which is a benefit of using
this. All right, so we get a bullish
swing failure. So, we take out this
swing low, we get a nice closure, and
then we're anticipating one to two to
three maybe candles trading higher. All
right, the next day is a bit choppy, but
we do have multiple opportunities in
here, okay? We have a bullish swing
failure here. So, we take out the low,
and then it closes, and then the next
candle, right? It comes down and all
right, it retraces all the way down to
this low, and then it eventually trades
all the way back above this candle's
high. So, there is a lower time frame
opportunity in here maybe on a 5-minute
or 1-minute chart, where you can
position yourself down in here on a raid
above this high. And then we get a
bearish SFP going in the opposite
direction in the afternoon. So, once we
get a bearish closure after taking out
this swing point, maybe we're going to
try and flip sides going in the opposite
direction anticipating the following
candles or series of candles are going
to eventually trade down lower. Now, I
could go through my charts for a very
long time and find so many examples of
this occurring on many, many, many
different time frames, but I'll leave
that work up to you guys. Okay, the
important part is that you learn these
concepts and practice them in the live
markets to see how they're actually
panning out. All right, because as you
guys can see, there are so many examples
of this actually working. Now, these
setups almost happen every single day.
But, the biggest key is that you're
disciplined and you're following these
setups and you're not just taking random
trades. You're waiting for the
confirmation and you're just trying to
take a short-term play in the opposite
direction after the SFP has been
confirmed. If you want to take this to
the next level and work directly with
me, I've opened up a few spots in my
inner circle program. I'll teach you the
lessons I've learned over the last 14
years, help you avoid the mistakes that
cost me a decade of profitability, and
trade alongside you each and every week.
I'll leave a link down in the
description. If it still works, then
spots are open, but if it doesn't, then
that means spots are closed for the next
enrollment. Now, I hope you learned a
lot from this video. Don't forget to
like and subscribe, and as always, I'll
see you in the next one.